c'est une petite pagaille qui a lieu
devant l'issue de secours de cette
enseigne de grande distribution des
clients sont évacués les grisons baisser
face à la venue de gilet jaune ils
bloqueront les portes d'accès une petite
heure pour inciter les clients à faire
leurs courses chez les commerçants du
centre ville
mais certains clients ne comprennent pas
on les soutient au début mais maintenant
non non c'est commencer enquiquiner tout
je pense qu'il ferait mieux de bloquer
les institutions plutôt que de bloquer
les centres commerciaux fois je vois pas
trop l'intérêt en fait pour les gilets
jaunes l'intérêt commun c'est pour eux
aussi confesseur
c'est vrai qu'il ya de la gêne sud
moment mais après non ils vont ils
comprendre la plupart du conte des gens
ils comprennent en principe tôt dans la
matinée des gilet jaune venus des quatre
coins de saône-et-loire avaient répondu
à l'appel du groupe de chalon ils se
sont retrouvés sur le parking du colisée
pour décider ensemble des actions de la
matinée et la mobilisation se poursuit
car les annonces des manuels macron
n'ont pas répondu à leurs attentes
moi j'attends de lui pas grand chose
attend surtout que les gens continuent à
se mobiliser et faire monter exigeante
beaucoup plus forte de justice sociale
de démocratie dans le mouvement il ya
quelque chose de fort sur la démocratie
référendum d'initiative citoyenne qui
sont des vraies questions pour que les
citoyens reprennent en maths toutes tes
questions qui les concernent
il faut que le peuple décide de son
avenir et de ceux de ses droits et que
ce soit plus une poignée de gens qui ont
les poches pleines qui décident pour
nous alors qu on crèverait on bosse on
leur apporte nos fric et on a pu ré en
fin de mois
les chômeurs il n'a pas non plus pour
aider les chômeurs tout ça en fait c'est
trop trop vaste en fait c'est parce
qu'on l'attend d'autres manifestations
ont eu lieu en saône et loire avec des
barrages filtrants